now Iran has been ramping up its threats
against journalists and dissidents as it
struggles to contain the flow of often
anti-government information as Iran is
rocked by protests dissidents are
fighting a constant battle to stay ahead
of Iran's intelligence services and to
get information out the committee to
protect journalists says 62 journalists
have been arrested by the Iranian regime
for reporting the death of Gina Masa
amini who was killed in the custody of
the morality police in September now all
of this means that many people rely on
foreign media outlets for independent
coverage of events going on back home
and DW's Persian service is one of those
for eight weeks in a row Nella far
golami and her colleagues have been
closely following the Crackdown on the
protests in Iran
their task amplifying the voices of
those that the Iranian regime is trying
to silence
today they have received footage of a
young woman who committed suicide after
having been detained by Security Forces
almost every day we receive video
footages from inside the Romper on the
streets of Iran and of course we have
some sources we have some connections
and some reliable sources that that
publish the videos that are recorded by
the citizen reporters because as you
know we don't have free Medias inside
Iran so that's that's the value of the
citizen citizen reporters with this
material DW's Persian language team
produces dozens of videos and articles
every day
thanks to bypass software such as Tor or
siphon people in Iran can access DW's
content
in spite of the regime's efforts to
block foreign media they try to prevent
pictures and images reaching us and they
try to prevent our content to reach
people in Iran but it doesn't work
because what we're seeing is a contrary
that we have a lot more or even four
times more Rich than we had before the
protests began but their work comes with
the price DW's Persian language
department has been sanctioned with a
travel ban by the Iranian regime many
here still have family back in Iran
they're fearing for their safety
the regime's arm seems to reach all the
way to Germany
some team members have even received
personal threats
the threats should be taken seriously
because in the past 43 years the Islamic
Republic has repeatedly attacked its
opponents in Exile with Terror attacks
and kidnappings including journalists
and political activists
imprisoning and torture is part of the
regime's daily routine but this Behavior
makes me Focus even more on my
journalistic work and encourages me to
be a voice of the people in Iran
despite threats sanctions and internet
censorship they will continue to inform
as best as they can about what is
happening in Iran
they call it an ongoing Revolution that
could last for months or even years
and the more we can speak to yelda
zabash who's head of DW's Persian
service hi Elder we just saw in that
report that members of your own team
have been receiving personal threats can
you tell us more what kind of threats
are they getting
yeah there are threats and in many
different ways first of all of course
the family is back in Iran are being put
under pressure and being threatened in
order to make the um us or the
journalists here to report less
critically to be less active on on
social media
um there has been one case where all
Instagram followers of one of my
colleagues had been called by Iranian
intelligence and in order to unfollow
um and follow this journalist and also
calling him a muharib which is a kind of
war against God and as we're seeing in
Iran right now this is one of the one of
the reasons um
people and demonstrators and innocent
people have been giving
um best penalties actually but um there
is so these threats are really um it's
not just one or two there's many of
those and the German Association of
journalists has called now for the
Iranian ambassador to be summoned and um
the police also takes these threats
really seriously yelda can you explain
to us how important social media has
become as a source of news for people in
Iran
very important actually social media is
the tool at the moment in different ways
and the one thing is that it's it does
serve like people in Iran right now it's
the only way for them to make the world
see what is happening in Iran because we
have a
um we have only States media and
propaganda and trying them the Iranian
regime trying to control the narrative
but with the people in Iran sending us
videos and sending us the footage
um we can verify those and we can report
on that as we've seen also uh in the
report and so but actually people in
Iran are risking also their lives in
order to get these images out there they
are filming for instance when other
other people are being shot or the
security forces and besages are really
cracking down on people and they can
also risk and we've seen also these
pictures like a young mother sitting in
a car filming and the next second seeing
her being shot
um because she so the only weapon that
the people in Iran have are their mobile
phones is social media and on the other
hand when we get this footage and report
on it it is also a source of informing
themselves about what is going on in
their country so they are they kind of
they are news gatherers and on the other
hand also
um being informed through this tool
Gilda thank you so much that's yilda
zabash of DW's Persian service